Amber Rose gets new ink swapping out an  old tattoo of her ex I love the element  of surprise  [Music]  it seems like amber is ready to move on  from her ex Wiz Khalifa the 33 year old  star has officially replaced her tat of  the rapper's face on her arm covering it  up with what appears to be a portrait of  rock star slasher Wow happening earlier  this month  amber showed off her fresh body yard at  the Sugar Factory American Brasier in  Florida since calling it quits with her  ex-husband in 2014 the model has been  covering the body mural little by little  with tattoos of roses meanwhile the pair  share four-year-old son Sebastian  together and amber opened up to et about  co-parenting with her former flames I  mean you know it's good we both love our  son so it makes it easy you know we  still love each other we're really  working on our friendship and it's going  really well and like I said we love our  son so it does make it easy  [Music]